welcome back we're on problem number 12.
problem number 12.
the perimeter the perimeter of a
rectangular plot of land is 250 meters
so the perimeter is 250 meters
if the length of one side of the plot is
40 meters
what is the area of the plot in square
meters all right so let me draw a
rectangle here
so let's see
we know that
one side of the plot is 40 meters right
well it's a rectangle so this side is 40
then this side is also going to be 40
right
and let's say we don't know what the
others if this side is x well this side
is x this is also x right so what is the
perimeter
expressing these terms
what's 40 plus 40 which is 80
plus x plus x right so 80 plus 2x is the
perimeter and we know that the perimeter
is 250.
is equal to 250.
and so solving for x we get 2x is equal
to what's 250 minus 80 that's 170
and that x is equal to
85.
right x is equal to 85
equal to 85
and now if we want to get the area of
this we just multiply the base times the
height so 85
times
40. put a zero here and four times five
is twenty
four times eight is thirty two plus two
is thirty four
so the area is thirty four hundred
square
meters i hope i didn't do something
wrong with the math but i think you get
the point
next problem
problem 13.
a school ordered 600 worth of light
bulbs six hundred dollars
six hundred dollars worth of light bulbs
some of the light bulbs cost one dollar
each and others cost two dollars so some
are one some are two dollars each
if twice as many so
if twice as many one dollar bulbs as two
dollar bulbs were ordered how many light
bulbs were ordered all together
fascinating so let's let x
equal number
number of one dollar bulbs
one dollar bulbs i could introduce
i could introduce a variable y
but i could just say that you know x is
the number of one dollar bulbs
and we know that twice as many one
dollar bulbs as two dollar bulbs ordered
right so what
how can i express the number of two
dollar bulbs
two dollar bulbs
well we know that twice as many one
dollar bulbs were ordered as two dollar
bulbs so this would be x divided by two
there are half as many two dollar bulbs
as one dollar bulbs right
and we know that if we add up the total
number of bulbs
well actually we don't know so what is
the total cost if we if we get x one
dollar bulbs and if we get x divided by
two two dollar bulbs
what is going to be the total cost of
this
well i'm gonna get x one dollar bulb and
they're each gonna cost one dollar
plus i'm gonna get x over two two dollar
bulbs and they're each going to cost
two dollars
and when i add it all up it's going to
equal six hundred dollars
so x times one is of course x
and then x over two times two that's
lucky that worked out plus x is equal to
six hundred dollars
so two x is equal to six hundred
is equal to six hundred x is equal to
three hundred
and they wanna know
how many light bulbs were ordered all
together
so we got 300
one dollar bulbs
and we got half as many two dollar bulbs
right x divided by two so we got 150
two dollar bulbs
we got 152 dollar bulbs so together we
got 450
bulbs
next problem
image clear
i'll do it in a new color
so we don't get bored
14.
if
four times x plus y
times
x minus y
is equal to 40
and we also know that x minus y is equal
to 20.
what is the value of x plus y
well we know x minus y is equal to 20.
so we can just substitute that right
here so then we get 4
times x plus y
times instead of writing x minus y we
can just write 20
times 20 is equal to 40
or if we multiply 20 times 4 we know
that 80 times x plus y is equal to 40.
then we know divide both sides by 80 and
we get x plus y is 40 over 80 which is
the same thing as one half
and that's our answer x plus y is equal
to one one-half
next problem
15.
in a rectangular coordinate system
that's what we're familiar with the
center of a circle has coordinates 5 12.
so i draw a circle
and then
the center of the circle
has the coordinates 5 comma 12.
and the circle touches the x-axis at one
point only what is the radius of the
circle so it just touches the x-axis
and the only place where it can touch
the x-axis only at one point is it this
exact because the x-axis is essentially
a horizontal line right and where else
can you touch the x-axis well you could
touch it here on top but if if the
x-axis was up here
then the y-coordinate would not be
positive so this has a positive
y-coordinate so we know it has to be
above the x-axis right it's at 12.
so we know the only place where you can
touch the x-axis just once is right here
right just right at the bottom so it's
got to be like that
that's got to be the x-axis and of
course you know
well i'm not going to
if that that could be the x axis and the
y axis could be out here someplace
just so you have a frame of reference
and if that's the x axis then what's the
radius well this is the point
five
comma twelve
this is
of course this is y equals twelve
so what is this height this is a radius
well that's just the y coordinates
twelve so the radius is equal to twelve
and that is yeah they're just saying
what's the radius of the circle well the
radius is 12. it's the y-coordinate
next problem
whoops
i say whoops a lot
problem 16.
and they have this let's see men
women
woman
and then they say voting age population
so population
and then registered
and they say twelve hundred
one thousand
thirteen hundred
and twelve hundred
say the table above gives the voter
registration data for the town of
bridgton at the time of a recent
election
in the election
40 percent of the voting age population
actually voted
so this is the voting age population
and we know that 40 percent
actually voted
if the turnout for the election is
defined by number
who actually voted versus divided by so
number
voted
divided by registered
what was the turn out for this election
so what's the number who actually voted
it's 40
of the voting age population so 40
what's the voting age population well
the total population is the men and the
women so that's
2500 just added these two up and what's
40 of 2500 that's
that's
2500
times 0.4
say 4 times 25 is 100
two more zeros zero zero
and then of course one decimal
one decimal so it's a thousand so a
thousand people voted for i just took
forty percent of twenty five hundred a
thousand people voted and if one another
turnout we just have to say the number
voted which is a thousand
divided by the registered voters well
the registered voters there's a thousand
men twelve hundred women so you add that
up so that's
2200 total registered voters so that's
the same thing as 10 over 22
or
5 of what is it 5
over 11. that's our answer that's the
fraction that that voted right that's
what they wanted right defined to be the
fraction so you could write it as this
fraction 5 over 11.
i'll see you in the next video hopefully
i didn't make a math error i'll see you
in the next video